sitting on a curb I'm homeless high
school dropout imagine being with this
young lady and you're draining and so in
this video I'm gonna share with you the
three things that I use to get fueled up
going positive going negative and going
neutral gratitude is my fuel I think
most people burn out because they're
looking for money rise and shine it's an
espresso time what's up believe nation
it's Evan my one word is believe and I
believe in you I believe you have
Michael Jordan level talent at something
and I want you to find it embrace it and
use it to make a difference so let's
start your day off right together grab
your coffee and sip on today's message
find your fuel over to you Eric Thomas
also if you want to hear at Eric Thomas
and other successful entrepreneurs have
to say about building confidence check
out my 250 for confidence series even if
you're my closest friend I have
boundaries hmm if you don't get to the
next level you're gonna have to give up
something right when I've been telling
you to get that gold get that dream and
I'm just been telling you drive it and
drive it and drive it and drive it what
I've been talking about is consistency
every day for the next 254 days I will
send you a 30-second to 5 minute video
for free every morning to help you build
unstoppable confidence the link is in
the description below
and I think when I started dating Dede
that was the first time in my life it
was like yo whew Wow no fuse like here's
this girl and saying like yo I got
dreams and ghosts really you know she
was the one with the dreams and go
always always went to school do what
she's for the goody two-shoes went to
school doing she was supposed to she's
the only child it was just her and her
mom you know she's very focused and she
was kind of like oh I like you I'd like
to have a future with you but if we're
gonna have a future together like I
can't I can't date a high school dropout
you know like I can't be with somebody
so she decided she got accepted into
college I'm going to college if you
don't get your GED and follow me like
it's a wrap
so imagine man we are 16 17 sitting on
the curb I'm homeless
high school dropout imagine being with
this young lady and you're dreaming and
you she's talking about when we get
older we got kids we don't live in this
house and I'm gonna be a nurse you doing
whatever and so for me that was the
first time in my life that it was like
y'all go whew like you know I could be
something I could do something so here
that for me that was and it was like yo
your dad is a high school dropout
your grandfather was hot and then no
disrespect cuz my father and I have a
relationship now so I you know I'm sayin
no disrespect to him but he dropped out
he had kids by different you know my
grandfather didn't finish yet and I just
was like oh I want to win brah whoa
starting a business is one of the
hardest things that you will ever do in
your life and you need to understand
what will fuel you to keep going every
day I think one of the biggest things
that holds entrepreneurs back is one day
you wake up and you're on fire and you
are moving forward and you were blasted
through your goals and it's the most
productive amazing gold chasing day ever
and you wake up the next day and it's
gone that fire that fuel that motivation
is hard to get out of bed anymore and
you look at your listed to do so you
don't want to tackle any of them and I
think the biggest challenge is that
starting stop and start and stop and
start and stop and I honestly for most
entrepreneurs that feel like you're on
fire maybe once a month it's just not
enough and you may not ever get to the
point where you're on fire 100% of the
time but you gotta move that quotient
forward you got to flip that percentage
so instead of once a month being on fire
it's only once a month that you're not
on fire and so I think part of that
self-awareness
understanding what it is that gets you
fired up and I share with you the three
things that I use to get fueled up going
positive
going negative and going neutral and in
what circumstances each one is helpful
so number one is go positive and this is
by far my favorite because I'm the I'm a
positive guy and optimistic I want to
see good things happen and someone going
positive is how I generally lean in on
getting my fuel and so step one would be
just putting on music if I'm ever down
if I'm ever slow low-energy
I just put on music that automatically
brings me up I think when people are sad
or depressed they tend to put on
Saturday press music that just makes it
worse that's just that now you're just
wallowing now you're living in that sad
depressed state if you are shattered
oppressed or unmotivated put on upbeat
music put on music that makes you want
to bounce and prepare that in advance
like today make your list of 50 songs
that you wanting to move so that
whenever you're in a low state you can
just play that music ASAP right away so
that's step one I also try to think
about my big why my little why'd the big
why is why I'm doing this the big
mission when I'm trying to accomplish
like if I don't get out of bed and do
this thing entrepreneurs are gonna be
let down you know I'm trying to solve
this huge problem I want to help a
billion entrepreneurs it's not gonna
happen we sitting in bed and then the
little why is just the the individual
people that you've helped sometimes the
big mission the division is just too big
you think you can't do it and if you're
in a if you're in a bad spot sometimes
thinking about that big mission feels
overwhelming and it just compiles on the
negativity the bad part you feel like
even worse because you're not going to
accomplish that big thing so just
remembering all the little people that
you've helped the individual the one
offs because if you can help one person
then you can help a million if you had
an impact on one person you can have an
impact on a million and so just
remembering those individual people only
helped three people in your life you
know maybe your business has only help 3
people total that's ok
think about those three people know that
you had a big impact on those people and
and feel the good that comes out of it
because I think humans are built to
serve and if you remember the time that
you served and how great that made you
feel then it's easy to kind of lift
yourself out of a negative spot and be
fuel to go forward so step one is really
just go positive dance think about your
big wire think about your little why
embrace a positive step to is go
negative if the positive isn't working
for you then you can go negative and
negative is thinking about all the
people who told you that your thing
wouldn't work out all of the things that
you have to go back to if this business
take off so think about your friends who
told you this idea was stupid think
about your parents who might be betting
against you and say this is never gonna
work you should go get a safe job think
about the job that you have to go back
to and how painful that was that old
boss you had that you hated and work
that you were doing those beneath you
that's what you have to look forward to
if you don't get up and go do the thing
that's gonna be your life and so you're
motivated more by the negative side but
they hate by the the idea of doing
crappy work for the rest of your life
even by regret that's the motivation and
gets you out of bed doing the thing it
can work and I like using in acute
circumstances you just don't want to
have to be in that zone every day if you
wake up every day fueled by negativity
then that is not a healthy place I don't
think to be in but in acute
circumstances if the positivity is not
working then you go negative and they
can give you that extra Drive you can
hand you a little bit more pain to help
you get through it
thinking about how somebody told you
that you could not do it can give you
the extra motivation just to keep going
on that day but you don't want to be
hating that person thinking about them
every day as a reliable source to get
you up so go positive wan go negative is
- and going neutral is a third and they
all seem to be against each other it's
just using them in the right
circumstances so when I use go neutral
is when I find myself being too worried
about the results as opposed to the
process so if I'm gonna try something
new if I'm trying a new format a new
series a new event something that I'm
worried about working if I look at look
at my event that I held in May it was
the first time that I had a workshop for
thought leaders I'm sure I'm training
thought leaders how to make money from
their ideas we're doing it again in
September and before I did the one in
May I hand in ha than I was worried and
I was nervous why was i nervous I was
really worried that I wouldn't work out
that nobody would sign up we ended up
selling out but you know that the
thoughts that go through your head is
you worry that nobody's gonna sign up
that it's gonna be this big bus and it's
gonna it's gonna look bad it's gonna be
a waste of time and because I was so
worried about the outcome
I just want neutral I said you know I
don't I'm gonna release the outcome I
don't care about the outcome where I
care about is trying something new where
I care about is just stretching myself
and seeing if I can launch a new program
and have it work or not and if it fails
great I know it fails and maybe I never
do it again if
works awesome I can keep going it's a
new path for me and if it didn't work
out I can find a different path that
will ultimately serve me but I may not
be this one and so releasing myself from
the outcome of this specific
circumstance by going neutral on the
result then allowed me to do the thing
that I was afraid to do and gave me the
fuel to get up and go and so going
positive going negative going neutral
using each of those scenarios in the
right circumstance to help you be fueled
because the most important thing is you
wake up every day you get out of bed and
you are off and you're motivated and you
were courageous and you're doing the
bold things that you need to do to make
your mission happen and build the
business that you want to build now I've
got a really special bonus clip that I
think you're gonna enjoy but before that
question of the day I want to know
between the three go positive go
negative go neutral which has been the
most powerful one for you to get
yourself motivated feeling bold leave it
down the comments below I'm curious to
find out thank you guys so much for
watching I believe in you I hope you
continue to believe in yourself and
whatever your one word is much loved
I'll see you again tomorrow morning for
another shot of espresso and enjoy the
bonus clip
[Music]
I think for me the the game is driven by
gratitude gratitude is my fuel I think
most people burn out because they're
looking for money they're looking for
short-term highs you know when when the
game itself and the process and
gratitude is the mix of your gasoline
you'll run forever when it's about
getting a watch or buying a new home or
getting a new pair of Yeezys you're
finished and so I see a lot of people
looking for quick highs I want to get
that girl I want to get that guy I want
to get that plane I want to get that you
know car that is just not sustainable
when you're like I cannot believe I'm
alive thank you so much and oh my god I
can't wait to wake up and fight and
grind and try to win it I love the game
you're unstoppable
I just never run out of energy because
those two things never run out the games
forever and gratitudes forever my
biggest advice to give everybody in the
world is like I say we live in an
external world everything is is you got
to see it touch its external if you can
for the rest of your life live inside of
yourself stop listening to people who
are calling you fat gay transsexual
[ __ ] everything that is makes no sense
all these insecure people putting their
insecurities on you you gotta flush it
out you got to just be whoever the hell
God or whatever the hell you believe in
if you believe in nothing but yourself I
don't care what it is you're gonna take
everything and throw it away you have to
believe in one thing and that is
yourself and and I'm not saying don't
believe in God or what you believe in
but right now for you to find greatness
in yourself you're not going to find it
by looking in a book
or by even hearing me I may give you the
spark but you've got to go inside
yourself to find it and that means you
gotta be quiet shut the go on the room
stop talking search your soul search
your mind search your abilities and
you'll find it but if you're not looking
for it
you won't find it so you got to go start
your journey and the journey starts with
you finding why the hell am i here on
this planet earth why am I here if you
don't know that you will live the rest
your life searching always asking the
question why raise your standard Apple
at the core its core value is that we
believe that people with passion can not
one drop of my self-worth depends on
your it's suppose to mean
I don't ever give up I'd have to be dead
or completely incapacitated hey believe
nation if you want to see my all-time
favorite top 10 most a success I have a
very special secret video for you these
are the individual clips that I have
personally learned the most from and
applied to my life and my business check
the link in description for details